مرحبًا ، هناك ذئب قبل لقاء رامشتاين الرئيسي مع
الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها الذين
يتوقعون الكثير من المساعدات العسكرية الجديدة
لأوكرانيا ، والولايات المتحدة بالطبع
تتصدر هذه المركبات الهجومية ومركبات مشاة
برادلي القتالية ولكن
الكثير من الدول الأوروبية الأخرى تفعل
الكثير  وكذلك تعهد السويديون أيضًا
بمركبات قتال المشاة ،
ودبابات القتال البريطانية الرئيسية ، ومدافع هاوتزر الدنماركية وبعض
الدول الأوروبية الأخرى التي
تعهدت أيضًا بتقديم الكثير من المساعدات العسكرية الفتاكة
الآن ، ويبدو أن القضية الكبرى هنا هي
الألمان ، الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤها
يضغطون على  يسمح الألمان بإعطاء
دبابات قتال رئيسية ليوبارد
لأوكرانيا ، وهذا لا يعني فقط
إعطاء ألمانيا هذه الدبابات بنفسها
ولكن السماح للدول الأوروبية الأخرى
بإعطاء هذه الدبابات لأوكرانيا نحن
نتحدث عن بولندا نحن نتحدث عن
فنلندا على سبيل المثال.  حسنًا ،
يمتلك الألمان بالطبع مفتاح ذلك لأنهم
الأمة التي أنتجت هذه
الدبابات في المقام الأول وقد تحدثت إلى
مسؤول أوكراني كبير اليوم
وأخبرني أنه يعتقد أن
الأوكرانيين يحتاجون إلى حوالي 600 دبابة قتال رئيسية
حقًا قلب المد في ساحة
المعركة ولكي تتمكن من استعادة
أكبر قدر ممكن من الأراضي وأنت
تعرف وولف الرئيس الأوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي ، فقد أوضح في وقت سابق
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك بالضبط ، وقد سئل
عما إذا كان يعتقد أن أوكرانيا يمكن أن
تستعيد شبه جزيرة القرم أم لا.  قال بشكل أساسي إن
أوكرانيا ستستعيد شبه جزيرة القرم إذا حصلت على
الأسلحة التي تحتاجها من الذئب